[Music]
[Music]
this episode of the handsome Rambler is
brought to you by bevel the first and
only shape system designed for course
curly hair and sensitive skin step up
your shave game and save by going to get
beveled cop / Hannibal that's getb ve
l.com / Hannibal what's up there's
another episode the hands of rebel
podcast I'm you hell's handlebars
co-host Tony trim here with our guest
Aaron I'm excited to be back in Chicago
man I've been in Atlanta why filming has
been it's been uh oh I'm almost done but
it's been a lot you're not filming on
the show Atlanta though not filming on
the show Atlanta just filming in filming
in Atlanta a lot of people filming in
Atlanta Aaron yeah thank you for doing
it so thanks for having me I won't
apologize about our first interaction
you told me about
where were we yet oh we were I think it
I think we were at the Whistler
we were somewhere on the Whistler yeah
oh no I actually don't remember I was
kind of drunk too but I remember what
you said yeah yeah wait you said kind of
drunk - that's assuming that I was drunk
of his story cuz I don't is that the
assumption I was drunk in this situation
yeah sure you probably you had a
drinking
so I'm assuming me could have been
holding for somebody but you know that's
well well I figured that's why your
first initial reaction to me asking you
where you were from was so cold you said
I asked him what was it it would you
can't you were there and somewhat aware
this is Hannibal and I was like hey he's
a comedian oh my god
sweet hey-oh
where are you from and you were like
Chicago really really you were like yeah
anyways tenant in it and you had that
this is the drink in the hand before I
did this
yeah you did this action which is a not
that card no yeah yeah it was just you
had a drink in your head and you were
like anyways apologies about that I'm
short with people sometimes it's all
good I mean after that I had good
interactions but yeah it was great
because it you know what happens where
people don't even what people say what
what are you doing here where would you
ask that uses that's where you from
sometimes people what are you doing here
what are you doing well that's I feel I
mean I'm I just like especially back
then I just wish I knew I was a singer
yet so yeah I was just making
conversation I remember yeah I was just
trying to you know you got a I was just
trying out nega nega
I was trying out negging that's that's
what you say something negative to a
woman and it's able to get a positive
reaction so you never heard of Megan
this is like this is like a real term
that I what is this from the 90s or
knows never the 90s as a millennial
thing
negging who who told you about negging I
think negatives when you just say some
playful slick [ __ ] to somebody so so
maybe you know that particular night you
came up to me are you where you from
I'll say snarky like Chicago and I
turned my back and then maybe I was like
peeking over to see so it's like a cry
for attention it's kind of like the
blade it's like the playground kind of
thing with the boy and the girl and he
called you hollow and you're eight yeah
using zinc like peas and then she looked
around and she's like no and she touches
him and that's when he's like that's
what I wanted but that probably wasn't
what was happening negging works at all
I think you should throw that one out
the window you know I work for some
women though everybody's don't know
everybody right everybody's different
you know somebody might think oh he's
playing hard to get and they might just
keep going and ask you more questions to
which you would just diss this yeah I
[Music]
didn't give you what I said that to me
with the angelic effect with the
handsome scrambler I think I would have
been like all right cool like what do
you do for fun I probably would have
started a conversation yeah if but only
if you had to have some scramble on deck
with the mic and everything on deck cuz
he's like this guy is really dedicated
to this [ __ ] yeah he loves music I'm a
music lover he's a music slaughters not
on it's too handsome scrambler I'm sorry
handsome scrambler we don't endorse then
don't endorse products that don't
endorse us actually you know what
[Music]
um why don't we make a beat I think we
should make his home you want to make a
song this is too hot and nobody else can
hear it except for us with these
headphones oh yeah you're right
everybody the people watching here in
the actual room no one can hear this but
he's doing the theremin and it's going
crazy and then he picked this up and
he's just yeah nobody else over here can
hear it it's all good though yeah
anyways I saw you in a movie I was just
saying this to him but I might as well
say it on interview but I saw you and
spider-man congratulations thank you
thanks a lot appreciate this man wasn't
spider-man and I took my phone out and I
taped it and I sent it to him thanks
plays a really great role in this movie
I played coach Wilson got about three
lines in there it was uh it was a good
time you said you went to school for
acting I did I went to Columbia Columbia
College downtown yeah I went to Columbia
I went for a theater performance and I
tell ya that education cost me a lot of
money I'm up and didn't get me [ __ ] not
much money um I don't think I can
divulge that information but it's hunt
thousands of dollars you better say a
hunter you cut it up because it's over
my mom and I cuz my mom's a great lady
but we're from Detroit you know I like
you know single mom and we don't have
the money she doesn't have the money
just send me to school so we took out
loans and she was like Aaron you sure
you don't want to do a journalism major
in addition to I'm like nah it's just
acting I'm gonna I'm gonna be an actress
you know what if this makes you feel
better I went to Columbia to for
journalism
thank you [ __ ] out of it so don't feel
bad what do you mean you don't a podcast
but this is look at you with your
theremin and you're handsome scrambler
and your jukebox but I don't I didn't
learn this in journalism yeah no but
you're giving interviews that's
journalism my mom just went out with
that I liked writing you know yeah so
she wanted me to go in and doing
something that involved me writing which
I do with music but she never saw it
until I did work with someone who was
like bigger than me and then she was
like okay it's cool that your prints or
chance came to Baltimore and everything
I was like mm-hmm
y'all was all telling me to give up go
to school and be a what they call it the
lady that does discern the thing for the
pregnant women what's that um what a
midwife no the sonogram technician they
wanted you to actually my mom didn't
want me to my mom always told me be zero
but she was like if you want to you
could do these occupations and they make
seventy five thousand dollars out of
college that seventy five thousand
dollars a year out of college and one of
them was a sonogram and I'm like I like
babies I like women no you go to the iTT
Technical Institute oh yeah
that's where you go you don't go to
Columbia for that yes I went to school
yeah yeah and then I I did Act
eventually but that was kind of
secondary wait but you what productions
did you do in college
yeah so I did like maybe like 20 student
films independent always try to get
signed by agencies I sent my you I sent
my headshots out to this one lady and
she was like those suck you have to go
get them done by this guy I go work like
a whole two weeks just to get enough
money to get pictures from this one guy
I get new headshots I send them out to
every agency and nobody picks up
so eventually like you remember the show
Glee yeah well they had this like
spin-off reality show on oxygen network
where they had kids from all over the
country audition to be on this show to
see who was the next star of Glee and
one of my friends my best friend Angeles
darling shout-out she was like Erin you
need to go to this audition I just want
to see if you'll make it and I'm like
okay so my birthday was right before
then we went out got drunk came back my
car got totaled and then I go to this
audition the next day and I don't think
anything of it but a month later they
call me and they're like come out to LA
we want you to be on the Glee Project
I'm on this tupid show this reality show
they fly you out yeah okay for this
stupid RIA yeah at least they flew me I
can say it now cuz like I just really
just didn't like it so much but I I went
out and didn't make it of course cuz I
didn't have the person I didn't want the
cameras on me so they want kids who are
like I do drugs are like just really out
there you know for reality so I wasn't
like that I didn't want the cameras on
me so they eliminated me like first
round and so when I went back home I did
like a a youtube videos my first youtube
videos like a cover of an Anita Baker
song I need a she's from Detroit so you
know I got feelings for her and I did it
and then these people flash forward that
were casting for South you know Book of
Mormon yeah probably yeah with the
creators of South Park some casting
director accidentally saw my video
YouTube of me singing that song my sad
song that's what that up next dude and
they were like yellow come out an
audition for these Broadway shows didn't
make it any any other Broadway shows but
it at least got some acting agencies in
Chicago to notice me and then they were
like oh wait come sign us and I was like
cool cuz I still hadn't gotten any jobs
at that point so
I want to talk about these student films
is 20 of them or did you exactly I may
have exaggerated there's probably like
no but for real between cuz like student
films could range anywhere from like a
two-minute video to like a 30 minute
video so doing a two-minute spot here
doing like a lot ad doing these things I
always look there's this board they had
up on our bulletin in the theater
department and someone smart in the film
Department decided to start posting
there are auditions on the bulletin in
the theater department instead of just
like posting it on Craigslist or
wherever they were posted and so I would
look at that [ __ ] every day
be like okay who what am I gonna do now
like and so then I just started looking
it I would take anything anything just
so that I could get an opportunity to go
to the next level because I was kind of
resting I didn't want to sing cuz I went
through a bad development deal thing so
I couldn't actually sing legally so wait
somebody's student films online yeah I
hope so
there's a really good one by TM white
and my friend Morgan bass what do you
play I play the girlfriend of course of
some dude it's a zombie it's a short
zombie film
yeah and that was my first one where
people were like yo cuz I posted it
everywhere and they remember those
circles it and that was the first one
that kind of like got me notoriety oh
[ __ ] we gonna splice that [ __ ] in I
played a girlfriend of this dude who's
cheats on me and then we were in this
mansion and he he just cheats on me and
then he gets eaten by zombies and that
was mine I cry I cry in it we are both
of you guys in Austin's new movies been
working I was supposed to be Austin and
I are really good friends and I supposed
to be but I was on tour so I couldn't be
in it oh you're in that movie though
right
I am a slice your slice that's that's
what it's called
you're an actor I'm a person 8 they put
in movies sometimes and they call it
active but I just
is this really Hannibal on camera is
baffling
every time I'm really you gonna I'm
gonna do this on a big screen Hannibal
Burres here I mean you're a character so
you are it is you that you play just
like an Spider Man I felt like that was
you walking along telling the kids to do
sit-ups and not the pieces of [ __ ] it's
just you know it's just me I am I on the
other hand I get cast as a prostitute a
lot after for so after that I got cast
as like my first big kick was on an
onion gig
yeah and they had me like being this
girl who wanted to suck off a
sixty-year-old
can I say things like this you can say
whatever though yeah and then I got on
Chicago PD as a prostitute and those are
my only two acting gigs besides Iraq
that I have that I ever had I feel
embarrassed around you but doesn't the
only two acting gigs that I ever had
that we're like and talking about we're
not gonna talk about Iraq here though we
you know I don't have super strong
feelings about chiraq I just remember it
was so much press around it and
craziness
yeah when I watched it I was just
thinking are they gonna sing the whole
time I didn't expect that
okay I hate musicals
it's a musical way that [ __ ] when I read
it I was like okay this is a like a
for-real adaptation like he's trying to
have prose in here you know and so I
didn't take it as like a serious film
about Chicago and being from a place
that is completely misrepresented or
misrepresented in media as Detroit I
mean we've had the most terrible
reputation for longer than she
I mean at least y'all got like parks and
[ __ ] you know like we do too wouldn't
you know it's just like there's never
been like we've had a pretty hard we
filed the worst bankruptcy in American
history you know and that's around the
time when I left is my mother lost her
job my father lost his job my auntie
lost a job everybody had to leave yeah
and Flint constantly gets [ __ ]
yeah and flakies [ __ ] I mean that's a
little far away from Detroit but you
know it's like coming from that place I
could understand why someone would want
to make a film bringing light to such
issues and when I read the script and I
did the read-through
it wasn't as terrible as I think that
everyone kind of tried to make it seem
in here like a lot of people watching me
my god it wasn't like I wasn't like
making Chicago look my head and look
here we are today 2017 August and nobody
talks about chiraq but in that moment
everyone was like it was just like God
like I don't understand you know was
bringing conversation to the tale I
think it's the a lot of people don't
like that term and that's that was
really a 10 and then when it was the
person making it even if it was Spike
Lee's today I think that's the initial
yeah just needs a only take two things
for somebody to be mad about success is
passionately mad about something from it
I don't like that work [ __ ] that [ __ ]
completely and honestly like as an
artist in again as someone from Detroit
where everyone thought I ate dog when I
came to Chicago like Chicagoans asked me
if I ate dog and I'm like what do you
mean do I eat dog they're like well you
guys are so poor they're your houses
aren't for [ __ ] and everyone's homeless
like you guys have to eat the stray dogs
that run on the street I got asked this
question at the airport by the way so
like and the person asking I said at
that eloquently this is why I feel like
no
they did some like you know media
portrayals of and just like how people
here are angry and I hear people's
stories about how they're angry about
this and that about Chicago I can
actually really relate right and I think
when I saw this film I didn't
necessarily maybe it's because I don't
live here that I didn't directly get
offended by it and I thought immediately
like what if someone were to make a film
about Detroit and actually about people
in Detroit a city that's been struggling
for the last like 20 years like I wonder
what that would feel like to have one of
the most you know important black
artists and directors make a film about
our plate about our about what's going
on you know and I kind of didn't
correlate anything else and I completely
understood and sympathized with the
people of Chicago over why they felt you
know bad about the film but having
agreed to do it and then did it and then
afterwards all the backlash was just
like oh my god I didn't even I didn't
know it would be this crazy or even like
before do you like to fill yeah I mean
you know Spike Lee film his films are
dramatic they're musical it's like going
to the theater it's not really like
you're gonna sit in it in a movie and
watch like a really intense you know
Roman Polanski you know it's just like
you're gonna watch theater almost you
know so I I enjoyed it where there was
it the best film I'm not gonna say was
the greatest film of all time but I
think his purpose was to say something
and put something use his platform to
say something that a lot of people
weren't about to say about Chicago I
guess you know and and I'm not gonna say
a lot of people cuz I know a lot of
people were standing up and speaking up
for what was going on in Chicago people
from here so I can't say that but I
think he was just trying and whatever
way he thought was good and I think it
just got misconstrued and understandably
but uh cuz he didn't cast chief keef in
it yeah you should have cat you know
Vick
you know I there was a lot of people in
it though to that I just respected I
went to the read-through and it was like
Angela Bassett and Samuel Jackson is all
these people that I respect
so much you know Angela Bassett played
in one of my favorite films Malcolm X
done by one of my favorite director
Spike Lee so it was like well this has
to be okay you know I didn't I've read
the script and I didn't think that it
was you know the craziest most
intellectual serious thing but I think
considering what he was basing it off of
you know musical I think I thought it
was okay and you know I'm still okay
with it and I'm okay to have been in it
you know I didn't hate it you know
Birdman now that movie was really bad
you didn't like wait Michael Keaton
oh gosh you hated it okay I enjoyed it
was a little boring but you know that
one was the direction was terrible I
enjoy Birdman a lot and I enjoyed the
shooting stopped hey it was a one shot
the whole way through or some one shot
but yeah you know what visual shot all
the way through
Oh visually is uh you know I enjoyed it
and I enjoy in hindsight more just
because some of the projects I've worked
on of move very slow innate and do it on
bird many not doing the turnaround
Angwin like this and let's do this well
maybe they did and put it all together
but he he hates he hates Birdman in a
very irrational way really why you gotta
tell us oh I've just Pat I passionately
hate that movie it's I think it was a
catastrophe that you play the worst in
what happened exactly
I'm baffled you know what movie I
haven't seen what a piece of [ __ ] that
movie was and how many awards have won
la-la-land what you think about have
y'all seen lalala I want to see it it's
a loser game I mean yeah it's a musicals
I just don't [ __ ] with musicals this is
not my thing I [ __ ] love musicals
you [ __ ] of musicals I I saw
fayla years back and I've seen I saw the
one you met the Book of Mormon and it
didn't you know what it was because they
hyped it up as being super edgy which it
was it was edgy but then it was Danny
irreverent the yes just about music I
want yeah like even in like the Simpsons
when they do like this when they go in
the song yeah because it breaks reality
it breaks reality and goes into like
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly I like music for one thing I
got made fun of as a theater student
though they hated that I didn't want to
be in like theater theater I'm in my
first day and orientation some dude went
off on me it was like you know who are
your favorite playwrights and I was like
I don't know I don't [ __ ] with
Shakespearean mary j blige just went in
on me like how dare you he went in and
that's why [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz that's what I remind me of a bunch
of [ __ ] theaters yeah yeah one camera
shot acting like I'm a theater kid too
like a theater I'm not I'm a theater kid
that's not it's like when people have a
cat and they're always like vouching for
the cab they're like my cat acts just
like a dog though it's kind of like that
like when people introduce me in college
they were like she's here to student but
she wasn't she's cool she's cool like
the worst of the theatre personality and
in one shot I thought it was good don't
listen and he plays baseball on
PlayStation 4
how could you wait that the Birdman
being bad movie a dog it's an amazing
game yeah baseball you just didn't like
that he PlayStation 4 is capable of and
you played baseball on it I don't know
anything about I don't have video
gameplay so it's very sensitive controls
the pitching is right on gotta warm them
guys up you get really into it the stats
the numbers maguet all I know is Sega Y
had a Sega Saturn and we had the soccer
game la la la my buddies are gay and we
play the duck game and we play come
about duck hunt yeah yeah
then we played we played the FIFA soccer
game and then we play some hockey games
in each other and then we played a sonic
old-school [ __ ] yeah and as alright and
then we got other games but I never
really like I told you I'm bad at
technology I can't say that can your mom
because she's saying she can harmonize
she was singing in the church choir when
I was singing at a jerk why she can
harmonize she likes to sing Chaka Khan
that's her favorite artist yeah that's
probably my favorite artist because her
your parents are musicians or they're
just music fan my dad played in a band
for a really long time it wasn't even in
college he played the drums oh nice did
you play any instruments I play piano
kinda yeah I used to play real good I
don't play so good so much anymore but I
create songs I'm able to create songs on
the piano mm-hmm but um my dad he played
drums and he played a little guitar he
was in a band for a while but his
hearing sucks now so it's like what did
that do fear he's in business you know
hey didn't do much to Beethoven but he
taught me the most about music like he
would always listen to Earth Wind & Fire
and all these
back grooves and just be like okay
where's the horn section who's got the
soprano or who's got the alto or who's
got this with me and my brothers and we
just kind of like know one of these yeah
that's what my dad would love this yeah
how does it how does it work with with
singers do you uh do you like do you
find your your pal first you were all
right one week after a lot of practice
that okay Robby I'll tell you the story
well he won't cuz he's not it being
interview but so I think it's like you
got to get in a student people don't
realize that when you sing singing like
in your shower is a totally different
story than singing in a studio when
you're in a studio and I'm on the mic in
the engineers in the other room and
there's glass and people can see you
first of all so mines getting paid so
his money online yeah well in my case
nobody was getting paid so it's just my
dignity on the line I was like okay and
I was always really really shy I think
that's why I did acting because I could
always take on a character you know yeah
I could always be something that wasn't
me so I was completely free and being
that but music and writing music and
writing is so vulnerable you have to
actually you know express yourself in a
way that can be scrutinized by people
you know so it's just like
so getting in a studio and doing that
and having eyes on you it's like you
immediately [ __ ] up hands down the first
time you're in the studio recording
you're gonna [ __ ] up so hard and every
time you do it it lowers your confidence
more and more and more and so it took me
a while to eventually like I think it
might have taken me like a year to build
my confidence and gain the voice that I
had inside that I sing in the shower
you know it's like you don't just get
that you kind of got to go in or if like
you if you're the front-runner in church
you in church every Sunday like that and
you just in there every day then is
different then you get in like an
affiliate but like for me it was like I
was always in the background in the
choir I was always in the background I
always sang background for people I say
you know I think background for chance
I think background for Vic I think
background for everybody general my
Norka actually sing so to step out and
be like actually I could sing and I can
write and I have something to say it's a
very vulnerable thing um yeah you gonna
[ __ ] up a lot it takes like a year or
two I feel like you're my case yeah well
you just buy one of these or you can
just buy it can I do this I'm gonna try
this how do I do this it's all now but
you can go
[Music]
[Music]
that sunroom I got eighties rocks huh
holy moly I can say yeah that was like a
journey song that could be yes not quite
thank you you have you bells written for
some people he like famous people no
have I coast ready yes I wrote this
nasty hook for an artist here one year
is when I was acting was trying not to
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're welcome to you great hook for
Chicago artists what was it do you yeah
she was fine you guys probably she's
actually really cool who her name well
Lily Kate
oh no I the brain of Lily Kate oh hey
look a grape
no I didn't Friday I back up thank for
jameelah woods though I think I'm saying
for everybody is known as coming up
right now probably but I did um an ass
y'all remember that little Wayne's song
and then I go and we lying here too
I was young
yeah I like a long-haired
kick rebound open up our legs the filet
mignon a pool stick I rewrote that from
a woman's perspective for an artist
named Lucci read you don't know she's
from Chicago she was on Bad Girls Club
but I rewrote the book wrote a hook I
don't even know was ever released it but
I was like writing stuff how'd it go
I forget her was it it was like nasty it
was like I went to my deepest darkest
nastiest place and I was talking about
dicks dicks dicks
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
ridiculous
no it's really gross and there was like
a whole chorus and we did guess where we
did a classic studio was I new classic
before I think he even ever knew I like
knew who he was for a long time because
I had like four or five friends that
would record their marriages record one
offs with people I had a friend all
dudes in college I was still trying to
do music so I would just like go right
little hooks for people or there's a
girl named Melanie or melody and I would
just write [ __ ] for her and then back in
Detroit I wrote for a girl grew your
supportive friend it sound like I mean I
just I guess I was just trying to not be
the front center of attention I never
wanted to be that for a long time
where's your birthday December December
statutory Sagittarius December 8th oh
that's not research that was just a
guess in my heart is December 3rd ODI
shadow mean nothing actually a little
bit baby I think it does people have
told me because I'm a Sagittarius that
sometimes I come off as being like
emotionless but I feel things
exactly but people should but it's been
like everyone throughout my life have
been like friends family like Aaron why
just why don't you pair and I feel like
I do you can't say that I don't care
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you think I'm dead inside
Sagittarius not dead inside Sagittarius
is not dead inside
we're not dead inside we're not in
motion the less please never say that
again
[Music]
yeah zodiac signs are [ __ ] so none
of that so use so use out here grab a
beer get me one too please man sure I
got this drink I still haven't finished
it's a drink made by Hannibal Burres
each horrible drink is it sir it's his
actual specialty it's is it yari doser
Jarritos I said no you said yar yar
result but it hardly thoughts and I said
you know let's do you know we could
still be friends [ __ ] he don't know but
it's hurry toes pineapple with the
tequila I think it with a plastic pint
of tequila you know I was it was getting
close to 6 o'clock I was quick I don't
like to look at story I said that Silver
Tequila will work and it just went
poorly with it it went poorly with the I
read those well you drink your they
quake everybody else Jaden no I poured
my meat into the sink cuz it was
terrible it's all good so
okay so sounds to me like you out here
giving out heaters giving out hooks
sounding all beautiful in the background
and then the show somebody somebody say
yo Aaron what the [ __ ] is you doing that
need to be you out there so stop giving
away these fire ass hooks and then just
keep the hooks and then you sing around
the hooks just somebody was an
individual or did you just decide on
your own
now don't be more profitable Oakland
accent right now actually I came upon
that on my own I went in college I
figured acting just wasn't working this
is before I ever was I I got my agency
thing and they were like you know we
don't [ __ ] with your girl I was like
[ __ ] I can't sing cuz I'm legally
bound I can't act cuz no one likes me
and I'm in these shitty student films
where I play the girlfriend of a let's
get back to this legally bound [ __ ]
contaminant oh you know is it no it's
cool I was in high school and these
dudes came to my talent show and they
were like we work with this person and
at the time just one dude who was work
who produced all the Big Sean stuff
which is how I met Big Sean which I'm
you know owe me whatever and he yeah
they were like let's produce your stuff
and then they did it and they just
sucked and then I breach contract cuz
they sucked and then they were like well
[ __ ] it in your contract it's a slave
contract you can't sing anything or
write anything or record anything with
anyone within 18 months after breaching
contract what Matt what was that
specifically what how did they suck were
they giving you beasts that are just
like yeah no yes they wanted me to be
Christina Milian and I wanted to be like
the up-and-coming Chaka Khan because my
mom like og way they wanted to be who
Christina Milian nothing against
Christina Milian by the
way I love Christina Milian but they
wanted me to be the cute like mix girl
[Music]
but I didn't even want my face on
anything let alone like that's why the
cover of my album now as no it doesn't
my face on it I don't like taking
pictures I don't like doing interviews
but this is cool but like I just like a
thing you know it so they wanted me to
be this like pop star and I just didn't
want to be done so they sent me all this
stuff and I wrote so many songs and they
all [ __ ] sucked
they're like that like dance but like
Dan si papi they were like papi arms
together and dog and then I started
taking I would take the bus home yeah
with my own money work take the bus home
the mega bus mind you one of the times I
took the mega bus my [ __ ] was so drunk
he pissed on himself and the people we
all had to kick him off the bus on the
side of the road was I'm sorry about
that it was just so bogus I would come
all the way home and I'd be like okay my
studio session starts at 5 I'm gonna
make music my life and then they
wouldn't show up for like 1 2 3 hours I
will go there and I would not have
somebody show up at the house and then
once I showed up it would be a studio
session in a basement which is fine when
you start now I didn't know nothing else
but it was just like after a while with
that spending my own money and doing all
that I was ass I got his candy what
eight from a major label
hell no so they were from like next
level entertainment Detroit so from the
sounds of it I'm just would I got no
insight on this is way beyond what you
just told me you just like they made it
seem like you would have been in breeze
but you probably could as did their own
thing cuz they sound like they probably
didn't have money to sue or anything
dude the dude's mom was like a judge on
the Michigan Court something he like
wrote it in an email and was like
gurgling so good
like we're gonna sue you for all you've
got you can't make another you said
nothing you already old about 80 to
Columbia I know I'm a mom that's why we
signed the deal it was high school when
I signed it they give you like any other
high school
no it was high school high school no
[ __ ] they were like girl we gonna
pay for you get in the concerts we don't
do this which I didn't care about but
they were like yo and they came to my
house we did a couple YouTube videos one
of them they made me sing Kelly Clark
not Kelly Clarkson they made me sing on
Keyshia Cole good that song Keyshia Cole
does I don't love you no no the one with
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] whatever I was singing that song
unwillingly not no thing against Keyshia
Cole I love that girl but again not my
style and they're having me sing Keyshia
Cole and I'm like okay they had me sing
it they do all this stuff blah blah blah
they say they have all these connects
and then they just got really like crazy
and wanted to do is ended up threatening
me a bunch of times he thought I was
like working with Kanye West because Big
Sean is sign of good music recently and
his producer was working with me so
whenever I hung out with his producer he
would think that I was talking to Kanye
West so he's like you better not be
[ __ ] talking to call my should be
Tony that might actually be able to help
you yeah no this is awful and I just
kind of felt chapped and I was like you
know what this is why I always wanted to
do something that didn't involve me
being like this spotlight so I went back
into hiding and then I didn't find my
voice until like probably my junior year
at college my dad moved to Australia to
work because you know everybody Michigan
lost a job my dad moved to California
and then he moved to Australia and I
moved there with him for summer for like
[ __ ] isn't it yeah it is I was just
smoking too much weed and chilling and I
was just like well I'll show you
he'll moved to Sydney and then he moved
to the CBD where the central business
district is and then he moved to
Elizabeth Bay which is like around the
corner not really you can take a chain
it's like a 10-minute train but um still
Sydney so he lived in Sydney and yeah I
just like I was just smoking when you
sit on my couch all day just feeling
depressed about like music about acting
and then my dad was like yeah you gonna
come live with me I was like yeah but
can they smoke weed out there he's like
no
no weed out here I was like [ __ ] I'm not
going and then he's like Aaron you
better get jobs out here so I went and I
just had this whole like detox of like
emotion and everything and then I just
kind of made a bunch of music and came
back to Chicago and that's how I met my
manager I was like I can't my professor
actually at Columbia I took a music
business class for my last course
oh and they were like one of the my
professors he owned a studio and I think
I got a record all the [ __ ] I recorded
and Australia so let me hit him up and I
went after class I was like yo can I
send you some stuff I want to enjoy
something he was like I understand to my
email since G was email and then
eventually he was partners with my
manager and they were in a car one day
and he heard my shitty recordings and
was like I'll cancel all my meetings for
today if you can just like bring her
into the studio and I came to the studio
and then I just started making music
Robbie over there actually probably gave
me a lot of my voice to be honest Ravi
really made me believe in myself so that
was a girl you know what I have a button
over here that says yeah I think that's
exciting also I still think that's I
think that's rude with somebody's like I
canceled all my meetings is that you
know what about tomorrow on some [ __ ]
I'll cancel everything and pay for it
out of pocket if you just like have her
come in and then I came in and it was
just crappy like I wish I could show
y'all I did horn sections so how I made
my music how I still make my music is I
make it from the ground up just using my
voice yeah so I'll do like bass lines
like boom boom boom boom boom boom and
then I'll do like the horn things like I
need these machines these UFOs I need
them but yeah that's how I make my music
so it
yeah that's what if I coulda added that
into my I think they would have been
like we're gonna throw money but because
I didn't have this machine they're like
you're on your own just [ __ ] sing
we'll try to get you whatever you get
well yeah next time I know I know I
don't still I'm still not signing so I
mean I can come by and use all this your
time come on through thank you got that
Robbie all right cool
just go do right yeah yeah I got all
kinds of fun stuff well you have a
studio in your house I got a Fender
Rhodes there I got a Rhodes you know I
put the keys right up a better than
butter had a sound that's what it was so
[Music]
you don't like razor bumps and you like
living smooth so do with bevel they got
the full shaped system in a futuristic
trimmer check them out at get bevel comp
slash Hannibal and save some cash that's
getb e ve l.com slash Hannibal eating
better is hard especially when you like
snacks so natured box can can help you
out with that they got over a hundred
snacks that taste good and are actually
better for you than regular snacks
they're made from high-quality simple
ingredients which means no artificial
[ __ ] flavors colors sweeteners none
of that so you could feel good about
eating if there's ever snack you don't
like they'll replace it for free they
sent over some snacks for me and
Hannibal before my favorite is a sweet
jalapeno juice sriracha roasted cashews
but I'm probably gonna switch that up
because I've been going vegan now but
they got vegan snacks too so for the
handsome Rambla fans we're offering
three free snacks which first order when
you go to naturebox.com/tyler that's
nature box.com slash Rambler and you get
three free snacks with your first order
[Music]
have you seen yes the only reason why
okay when I first got one of the only
one of the biggest I'm like icing on the
only one of the biggest reasons why I
signed the CAA music Agency I'm not
siding with him anyway the biggest
because Rob light who was the president
music he Stevie Wonder's like agent and
manager and he told he was like talking
about the tour at the time and they were
like trying to swim me because there
were other agencies and I was like
mm-hmm
and he was like yeah you know he's on
tour and like not him himself but
everyone else was a gays on tour and
this and then I was like if I if I sign
then that means I could probably get a
ticket to see Stevie Wonder and I've
never seen seaville I've met him in
person at an herbal shop in Washington
DC but I had never seen him and for
someone who knows a ribbon in the sky
but over phone like someone taught it to
me over the phone and I know it I was
like I have to you know see this guy
loved great friend yeah that's a great
friend and yeah so I was like [ __ ] so I
signed and this evening then me and
Robby would he like he forgot that that
was a stipulation like you got to get
his tickets so that Stevie Wonder
concert and then like a day before I was
like Robbie can you hit a proud light
and remind him that we have to go see
Stevie Wonder and it's here in Chicago
yeah at the United Center and he was
like okay I'll try you know there's no
guarantee like obviously I'm like no
problem he hits them up we go we're not
thinking about and then we get our
tickets and they keep telling us to go
down and down it down we get third row
center Wow
on the floor Stevie Wonder my first time
ever seeing him in my life and I've out
passed out like four or five times
boy you legit blacked out I think I did
same thing with prints like I I kind of
black out when I see people that I love
just like up there that I'm like older
but still killing the game you know is
this you know me and I Hannibal when we
did the the Flint we did a we did a
benefit in Flint Michigan for the water
crisis and Stevie did like unannounced
whatever and it was crazy because he had
his uh you know guider
his guide guy yeah can't bring any so
he's he's just kind of like kind of
going up there so he sleaze older
obviously he's blind so he's kind of
stumbling or not stumbling but he's
walking up slow Danny I'm not talking
just saying this is how this is what I
saw he sits down it gets in front of
piano feels around the piano and then
the swish just [ __ ] hits right and he
just goes right just goes right in have
y'all ever seen him I didn't miss a step
I saw that yeah and uh I saw him yeah I
mean you didn't in Vegas a couple years
ago I it was actually Thanksgiving
weekend in Vegas and I bought some
tickets off a StubHub and then it turned
out to be tickets upfront where you get
to take the chairs with you was the
songs in the key alive short and what
what was the obvious show was great and
you know it's great uh never get your
chairs did you take a chair I didn't get
two chairs back okay it was that's
enough that's a separate story
what's that separate right this is what
what I found it was dope about it show
is he's a really funny guy because
india.arie was guesting on his show and
she would come out at different points
of the show and uh she would come out in
a different outfit and he would say look
at Indy re with that yellow dress on Oh
in the Army you in that white dress now
huh
that's awesome sounds great and then I
saw him at the garden at the garden uh
maybe a year after that is so and he at
one point just started singing Fetty WAP
this is one no he didn't know this was
the song maybe he saw it he just started
singing my way this is at the this is
Fetty WAPs peak - I mean like this is
and he just jokingly that's awesome -
just sang the hook real quick and then
went about what he was doing you know
that's awesome no no no no that happened
in a South Africa when I was in
Johannesburg at the airport some random
African do is they come I just walk up
to you that's what's he a limo driver is
the airport worker he was just saying
it's his limo pitch or something he's
like a taxi drivers getting some kind of
tip I think he was like but still it was
just
yes Stevie Wonder's the best yeah yeah
you know so those chairs
okay well it's too long of a story I had
to do that on my own time somewhere else
but you stole them you know to you right
yeah yeah I took them to my hotel did I
that I was I was gonna stand at the
Doubletree Santa Monica this was
Thanksgiving weekend 2014 and then I
ended up it's just tough to travel with
chairs and I'm that organized enough on
my own to just handle just packaging
them up and sending them
so I was just gonna get him back when I
came back to LA and I did come back to
LA in April or May to do my TV show at
the time and so I hit up the Doubletree
and I said where's my day I left these
chairs there and which is in an
obnoxious time to leave somewhere
something then and hold and they work
here we remember the chairs they were
real understand we don't call you back
we remember the chance then they called
back and he said we don't have the
chairs but they gave them to us
that means they gave them to somebody
that worked there nobody just took the
chairs they fly could Stevie won the
front row chairs they got the [ __ ]
songs in the key of life album designed
on him you know exactly what he shares
and so they try to say they say oh we
you know the chairs of God enough so
you're not sweet at the Doubletree main
Doubletree account say hey I left these
chairs with double tree Santa Monica
they initially said that they had I'm
not in that Santa they have them and
then about two hours later I got a D
Emma said you sure as a waiting adult
[Laughter]
maybe I should use Twitter more often
because I feel like I've left it and
then it doesn't they're like we can't
find it you know yeah I mean I don't
know but you know they gave it to
somebody that works okay you got a
following they're gonna do everything
they can
well I wasn't sometimes just sometimes
you get angry when you we travel in and
then you just start just that's right I
try to try to get away from that and in
recent years what should what's your
favorite city datura okay so I just went
on my first tour ever this past year
Danny drove for me actually so how many
see how many cities do we go to
they don't know like 27 over the course
of around three months but one of the
months we had some time off so yeah it's
we're with gallant I don't know if you
know I'm not sure
okay what's the was a gallant song was
it ooh
what's up hurl a mile away go do you
know pulling my
[Music]
Wow he did the song with seal actually
he actually did that song with seal but
anyways kiss rose yeah kiss from a rose
notice the lines abode [ __ ] with
us seal came when we were in Los Angeles
at the Fonda there was two sold-out
shows much at the Fonda Theatre in Los
Angeles and seal came and performed at
the last night and I like had to go I
felt like wrong going up to him cuz I'm
like you though I don't really like
talking to people because I got [ __ ] to
say so I don't really never go up to him
but it's sealed it's kiss from a rose
yeah no that's his name really and I'm
like I gotta go upstairs my daddy's like
my dad music kid like biggest seal fan
so I was like I gotta go up to him and
honestly the story doesn't have a climax
I'm sorry about that but I just went up
to Robbie hates it when people tell
stories like it's gonna have a climax
and it doesn't have a climate well I saw
somebody famous this is not a climax
either I saw okay I just saw Anthony
Rizzo at Lollapalooza but I screamed at
him who's Anthony Rizzo he's the first
baseman's Chicago Cubs okay he's a top
he's the top guy okay anyways so he
walks by I'm screaming out um he turns
her out
thanks yeah says is there access totally
said thank you done when I'm out and
about is now how I'd go before like how
about like what are your biggest fears
in life I don't know if you know but I
think there might be a thing where like
your first interactions with people you
do that what's it called what Nega
no it's not is that a thing your first
interactions no no it's just it's it's
mood related super it's just varies on I
mean you know the the whatever people if
people recognize me that's the same all
the time but how I feel in that moment
isn't that the same should say when they
don't even know his name and they come
up like hey or do that it's like come on
what is it I'll be very kind of what
people say uh where do I know you from
and I say hey you go figure it out on
your own time and then come back to me
what you got let go
don't make me I'm just walking around
don't like make me explain
yeah so we wrote and I let them know
that that you built a wall no so now
you're like a stone like anybody that
comes up to you you like you're waiting
like you know you see people with their
you know you can see people kind of hype
themself up so you see people thank you
creepy yet both stand in the corner and
then they'll be like there and then all
of a sudden they're and then right
behind you like yeah maybe [ __ ] I'm not
at that level of Fame you about Charlie
Brown I mean not Charlie Brown all right
[Laughter]
Charlie Brown that was a sages is this
stupid hairy toes in tequila you
handsome I meant to say Charlie Murphy
person whatever no but Charlie Brown all
these mushrooms salad
I met him at an airport and like I just
love did Dave Chappelle show
I like yeah no no no it's a long time
ago like when I first went to college
and I was like exiting to baggage claim
my brother was coming to pick me up and
I like walked out and he was standing
there and I was like oh god it's like
Eddie Murphy's brother was anyway what's
up is Eddie Murphy's brother he's like
my name is Charlie and then he walked
away he didn't say anything I was a
little girl a little sweet innocent girl
and that just showed you how fed up he
was with people but I left like I didn't
even think twice about I just was like
as is funny cuz like I didn't like I
called him Charlie's brother so I had
that come in but yeah I just knew I mean
Eddie's brother that'd be funny of you
got Eddie Murphy Charlie's brother now I
keep thinking in my head last name first
name Charlie yeah that just of my head
is weird in wheaton Charlie Wilson do
you have a Charlie Wilson story I don't
have a Charlie Wilson story I didn't
remember was that did I just get the
Chicago wherever I get I think I just
got to Chicago's on a lower level at the
airport and I think it's the week after
spider manages came out and yo a group
of my white 10 euros rush me man like
eight deep I was like oh no what have I
done what you know look is that's ripe
in the MOOC like I don't know what movie
but he was a bunch of little kids was
never my yeah he would have come usually
around know and it's a certain yeah
demographic and then that part of it and
that was like oh [ __ ]
this is weird and then this kid maybe
not he had this right here is kid inside
him and so he
I think I just hopped off the plane I
was tired as [ __ ] and then uh and then
we took it and then I kept on walking he
was like yo let's take another one you
don't look good in that one and then he
just went and it hadn't even act like
that was a crazy thing to say he just
went back into taking himself and I said
hold on bro I was [ __ ] sleepy
I had scared that new generation ya know
generation right there I'm scared of
that one who is not a not everything
that all of it is an idealization or
even being a legit fan sometimes it's
just kind of especially in my case is
vaguely recognizing me from something
emulate he was in there no I mean if
they if they could connect you to the
[ __ ] dead that uh that uh dachshund
from secret life of pets you know hella
kids fans wait but they can he was the
dachshund
he was the dog the little hot dog he was
also an angry birds I watch secret life
defense secret life of pets like maybe
fact I watch it to go who's bad he's a
boxer I don't know why I never knew that
you weren't in there yeah I'm a piece of
[ __ ] that's right cuz it was a it was a
dog and I really transformed my voice
for the role I really tried to embody
the dog you killed that [ __ ] have you uh
have you done any did you do any anime
exact thing no but everyone tells me I
should do it cuz I have like a million
different voices that I do for people I
can see you doing it but you have a
million
oh yeah yeah like if I know you then if
I know you will enough I could probably
imitate you yeah maybe if you if you had
to play a dog in a movie at what would
your dog voice sound like I do any right
now yeah do it right now rehearsal
now the spotlight now I have to make a
good dog voice otherwise you're gonna be
disappointed
don't get all scooped what's my dog
named Felicity felicity
oh good like the girl on WB snuffles so
Felicity or Nina I'll give you some
other pictures whatever makes you
comfortable okay what am I saying
what is the dog the dog the dog is
trying to break up a fight between the
other dog but not a dog fight like
Michael Vick [ __ ] like they just arguing
and you are the voice of reason and they
listen to you all the time so it's up to
you to get these dogs about to really go
at it and you have to say something
about them and make remind them about
their friendship to get them to calm
down
oh this is too hard okay yeah and then
I'll play a pit bull and weird when you
guys are fighting and I'm trying to
break into the boxes name the secret
life of pets you know that's the secret
life of pets is his buddy his buddy but
you know just as I set up that scenario
and put her in a kind of cookie cutter
stereotypical female role yes white
female role like we don't want the phone
then that's automatically gonna be the
thing so we gotta switch it up what if
I'm like the dude dog getting into the
fight yeah the guide dog what if I'm the
guy down you could be the tough female
dog cuz he's loved a female voice
nothing wrong with being a female no
nothing I love being a female oh there
you go
well what's the scenario here should we
just grab it No
[Music]
we bail on bit sometime when you go back
home do you slip into an accident more
you think people think people from
Detroit you have country X's I've
noticed that everywhere I go even here
when I came here people like people
thought your accent Wisconsin people say
car get in the car
i'ma do hell I'm like hell I say hair at
least like Chicago people say what's the
Detroit accent like don't know but I
know a suburban Detroit accent it's
similar to the Chicago suburban accent
where it's like yeah I can give me the
keys in your car I'm gonna go out there
yeah it's like a little they elongate
their eggs and their car so like all
like Danny say something like a like a
Chicago accent like the Northwest likes
I'm gonna go like Lake Wisconsin why
why'd it yep
yeah but not Wisconsin II though it's
more like polish Italian if I go I can't
even [ __ ] do it I'm right I suck
maybe so I never yeah no not gases they
[ __ ] maybe not you sound kind of like a
it's the Chicago accent is a citizen
deep-dish big headache changes in deeply
I know I had eggs I found out there's
certain words that Chicago
and say that then I'll say them when I'm
elsewhere and they people say whatever
you talking about one there's overused
is decent decent really decent cuz
decent I think among if black people my
age and younger know like I think among
Chicago black people decent means can
mean amazing yeah was that part it was
decent oh I see what you're saying and
so I said something was decent when I
was in Atlanta and is gross what the
[ __ ] why are you it was you are you okay
why do says is DS oh I don't know I'd
Chicago people the only thing I'm ever
really noticed from Detroit was that
some people say different words like car
and hair and mom they say more with a
Southern drawl like as if my cousins
from Tennessee like my cousins from
Tennessee would say but like the south
side acts yeah like I went to the bottom
of country I said I went to the month
yeah it's like a more southern jaw cuz
back when the Depression hit a lot of
people in the South that's exactly why a
lot of people are in Detroit cuz they
look for jobs in the Midwest and but I
don't know I don't think Detroit has
anything except for what up though is
the Rope is the rumor about Detroit when
Eminem comes to a grocery store
everybody has to stand still and say he
gets his stuff in the grocery store in
the Detroit metro area yeah everybody
has to stand still with this stuff he
gets his time I can't imagine anyone
trying to stop from Bryan ish that's
another thing about Detroit that I
realized - is that like I feel like
because Detroit people are so like about
telling you you know real people you
know working-class it's not a lot of
famous people come out enjoy you know we
got Eminem but you know if he came to a
story big shot Danny Brown teairra Marie
dear we gonna vote his we got Diana Ross
we got whole Motown we got Hearst
Michael Jackson was found by Diana Rob
Barry Gordy we got Stevie Wonder we got
all those we got all those people
probably got at least one Instagram over
three hundred thousand maybe we got one
Instagram honor I don't know I'm not
making you try like that right now so I
don't want to be like saying that but
yeah I think Detroit people are just
like because we're on much smaller scale
than Chicago people are just so much
more real with each other so I think if
everything were to walking through a
grocery shopping you know like people
are just like so I don't know I like
white is not really ruler to be true
because I like it maybe I shoot I don't
I'm gonna give him an and walked in some
people will be like oh that's a man ooh
what up but I don't think anybody would
ever like like I mean like here if Kanye
West can't walked into a store people
will be like oh my god I mean anywhere
if he came to Detroit people but even
him I feel like it's such a he's such a
regular dude in Detroit I don't feel
like nobody really trips well I'm being
in a grocery store but maybe maybe some
maybe that happened one time no I left
that city or something I made up to our
podcast how long is the podcast can we
just make a beat now wait let's make a
beat okay let's make a beat alright
let's make a song listen this will be
the outro of the whole thing okay you
got to start with the percussion
[Music]
we got em I got em I got em what are you
doing are you shopping for Slim Shady
oh wait wait wait Slim Shady Slim Shady
up and out five chickadee get in line
crap brains and some green berries
[Music]
sunshade you got those games in your bag
[Music]
sure sandy bears bears put all my shoes
they dress shoes best believe I'm
jealous
[Music]
you best believe gentlemen you want to
get away you want to hear the way it
handled works his working process on
music this is this is how he develops
music right here do it
sports sports not gonna [ __ ] outta you
thought up with a team word we got the
team word but the team synergy energy
energy energy that's a reference track
that's a reference we were listening to
a bunch of songs early you get that uh
you know what type of music you got you
got that girl you helped me through a
lot of [ __ ] music needed that [ __ ]
dragon tragic courage yeah it is pow
you be singing yeah yeah no yeah I mean
I kind of try to speak things you know
that people that I'll resonate with
people so the people come up to you
crying sometimes I not mostly like I've
had some people but that's like rare but
yeah I've had some people come up and
you'd be like yeah I mean I don't really
know I don't set out to make people cry
or feel any types away I just kind of
write about the things that are going on
maybe in the world there maybe with
myself and then I think you do what it
does ya figure if I put it out into the
universe
somebody's gonna be able to be like oh
[ __ ] because I write kind of arbitrary I
kind of write like um just loosely
enough to to allow the audience to
interpret the music for what it it for
what they think the lyrics mean I don't
say like I'm on my cell phone texting my
man and then he know him 'back and I'm
so sad I like text I like say it in a
different way that's not so obvious so
that if someone like if the if they're
going for the text situation or if their
grandma's dying or if there's some
situation I just write it based off of
I'm feeling and then write it write it
for yourself and then let every yeah and
then if they like it I like it I think
that's the beauty of it is that you kind
of just do what you do and then if
people like it then they like yeah
that's how I feel about when I'm doing
my jokes about airport food and TSA
having like yo there's art people take
it out they take it but also
I'm only writing these TSA chokes cuz
I'm on a deadline right now and they're
they're very easy for me to hit they
make a connection oh it's your tragic
courage tragic certain times clinging to
clouded easy as it say
can you think to it sometimes claim to
sing that aims he has a Saints bones
and try trial in traction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
you can't
well you sing beautifully
honestly you blended right in I thought
it was my back vocals and then I was
like oh [ __ ] it's you know yes the
machine this is the machine I've never
had a problem finding the pocket it's
just I'm not supposed to be there
normally timing wrong tone wait
exceptions and this one is more
exceptions yes a lot it's a lot of stuff
on it yes I love the names November guns
what is this don't you know that's
November rain go into Co November rain
oh I heard I heard this was your
favorite song not this song
please the trees come on the services
good that reminded me about via that
attic room and I think
shuntay was DJ and then at one point I
don't know what song was on or what but
you would just kind of weirdly scatting
on stage and maybe we had met before but
that was the first time we really met I
don't remember the song I think that's
my calling is just scatting it was you
having a great time okay yeah yeah Savva
then I get an oh my be in ago at a sword
like mace windu
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
DJ's are like shouting over the
microphone and everyone can't really
hear them but then the it's like people
still react hey I remember that's what I
was trying to do it worked it worked
didn't it yep okay well this has been
fun there that's a good time thanks for
coming dude we didn't make our classic
beat but yeah we do we have a lot of
time for that we have a lot of time yeah
Etha shout easy shout was peace or else
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah thank you Eric thank you so this
is 15 we got quick 15 in a minute
intermission is two hours of this so uh
[Music]